taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them hey folks
it's taste buds i'm joe my name is
salvatore volcano hi
sally we got a special fourth of july
episode today
yeah summer snacks episode what are you
putting out at your picnic
what are you going to first the potato
chips in that bowl
or the bowl of the pretzels there's
usually a bowl of both out
at any at any decent picnic you could
say you want to throw a cheese puff or a
popcorn into the mix but everybody knows
chips and pretzels are the natural
adversaries they reign supreme
and people love them both and people uh
favor one or the other and we thought
it'd be a really good matchup because
we've been seeing a lot of potatoes and
pretzels out there during the barbecue
season
yeah yep yep yep i'm going to a barbecue
today
you are you are going to a bar i'm
looking forward to that uh all right
so with the shirt
this is my friend brian mccarthy has a
podcast he's very funny and he makes
these shirts
or not makes them but this is his merch
i told him i'd give him a plug i'm just
making sure that is such
like a hot topic spencer's type of shirt
yeah yeah
you know what i mean like yeah like he
wore that like i would wear that like
you know high school or something like
that yeah he made the other one i work
i'm not confident enough or cynical
enough to wear that do you get fried
friday may i have fries with that shake
well i wore
on the other episode oh wait that one's
not out yet this one comes out first
you'll see it next week
anyway it's the same same store brian
mccarthy's merch store
go to uh lipswet.com
and uh there are you you go to it
there's a button that says shop and you
click on it and
there you go lip sweat.com
yes interesting so anyway he's a funny
guy and he's got a lot of funny
shirts lip sweat and i'm not wearing it
to you know just as a
it's not a sponsored thing i just
thought the shirt was really funny yeah
you give me another friend up a plug
yeah exactly i like it uh speaking of
friends
and friends treating each other the way
they're supposed to
and not doing things to antagonize their
friends and
rub their noses and things and be mean
for no reason
i uh received a couple pictures pimp
last week from
this man two days in a row
two days in a row first day crab cakes
and and tacos i did it to you yeah you
did tacos tacos already went out to the
internet
i know and uh you you got what you
deserved on that
this week he sends me a picture of crab
cakes
says they were absolutely phenomenal
they were den sends me a picture of him
eating a pear
saying it was delicious then we get here
today and he goes
you want a pear cider it's one of the
best things i've ever tasted i mean what
are you doing to me dude
so i went to the beer warehouse whatever
it's called
and i got a variety for the fridge for
when we have company
and uh i chose pear uh as opposed to
apple cider because i thought it was a
nice curve ball
and then i tried it and it had a subtle
pear taste and i really enjoyed it
yeah yeah that's it paris there's no
real story he has no scandal
no i know but i mean you know for you to
talk about that's the way you did and
talk about crab cakes we did i never
would order it because i would never get
excited about it then you send me a bowl
not what i said we could even do one of
those things where he throws in what i
said
in this episode don't speak out make it
sound as if you could care less about
the crap
i love crab cakes i agree they're good
but they have a ceiling
when you make them the right way they're
great and that's about as good as you
can get with them you can get
someone that knows how to make them the
right way but at the end of the day
they're pretty similar to the word
absolutely
phenomenal because i went to this place
phenomenal it was amongst one of the
best crab cakes i've had which you said
was
impossible you said was it a possibility
you said you couldn't
get into phenomenal territory with a
crab cake that a crab cake has a ceiling
and that's it it had a ceiling
it was amongst the best i've had within
its ceiling and so i
i i said that i ordered them i said that
i liked them and i'm not going to stop
doing that i love crab
but against the lobster roll i maintain
the lobster roll
when i'm taking the best lobster over
it's the best crab cake i'm going
lobster all every time
i'm gonna send you a crab cake picture
because you're my friend and it was very
appropriate because we just had an
argument over it and i was eating one in
all fairness
last week i ate i ate a man he sloshed
out a piece of [ __ ] and it was really
good a big one
not even a punk spot or lobster it was
really good
oh my god it's all smoking mirrors here
people
pull back the curtain a mayo one
you couldn't even get what it might have
said in my definitions
in my defense your tongue couldn't even
touch a male loss
my defense and these were the waiter's
exact words i go
is it a mayo or a butter base roll and
he goes mayo
but not a lot of mayo so don't worry
about it
he went he unprompted was saying to me
i know your fear of the mayo i i get
this all the time
the mayo does not ruin this because mayo
can't you could hear that he was saying
mayo ruins a lobster girl
the only place to get a lobster roll is
that's lobster bar but besides that
where'd you go
i forget the name but it was a really
nice little seafood spot
okay i went with a friend of mine and uh
and we had
she and i had uh uh oysters
and martinis dirty martinis and oysters
excuse
everyone yeah and then we had a couple
shrimp cocktails
very adult yeah and then we split a
lobster roll wow
yeah oysters and martinis huh what
happened later
uh nothing cause we say nothing because
we smelled like gin and
fish you had ginger
gin and fish that sounds terrible yeah
yeah uh i will tell you
and uh full disclosure uh i have come
around slightly on pairs
okay i came home one day there was a
rogue pair here
uh and i i said you know what effort i
took a bite out of it
i will say though i need to find out
what type of pair that was and where in
its life cycle it was
because whatever it was it converged to
that day to be
absolutely un i mean i would be
a pair a hardcore pair of fanatic if
every pair i had was like the pair i ate
that day
the problem with him he's talking like
these are exotic pairs
they're green pairs it's the pear you
always see everywhere
because the pair i sent you that i was
eating yesterday was ah i was okay
but i got i got pairs in the mail from
someone
sent pairs you know and so i thought i
was gonna have the same experience i had
with the pair a few weeks back
and i bit it and it was not anywhere
near and then i was told
give it a couple days not right yet i
gave a few more days it still wasn't
near
and now i have pears in a bag downstairs
trying to get them to where i got but
i'm realizing
i don't understand how to tell you this
but the consistency of this pair i bit
into
was so juicy and soft and smooth and
not overbearing and delightful with
succulents
if a pair could bat a thousand all the
time good for the pair
all right but that pair on that day was
terrific all right i have not gone back
on my cantaloupe opinion it's a
disgusting fruit it tastes like [ __ ] and
unless you wrap a piece of salted ham
around it it's unedible
all right so i stand by that okay yeah
this is big because you said there's
something wrong with people who buy
pears
indeed indeed but to be fair i mean the
pair is inconsistent at best then
maybe you don't know what the f you're
doing maybe that's what it is it could
be
you know you're going to throw a whole
fruit under the bus where
maybe you're the problem i've been
steering a ship that is my life for 44
years and i think i'm doing fine
you tell me i know what i'm doing
because i i can't get a right pair in my
mouth i'm saying
when it comes to pairs yes i don't think
you know what you're doing
and i think that it's unfair to say the
pair is inconsistent
when it comes to the constant in this
equation is you
picking different pairs wrongly
obviously when it comes to pears do you
know what you're doing
no idea really no clue it's a
complicated fruit it's hard
it's hard to pick right but that's not
the pair's fault it's a learned fruit
you have to learn the pair but when you
get it right it's great
but you gotta get is that on there or is
that on us it's
on the pair it's it's you know so it is
that's a strike against cantaloupe is
very similar cannibals are hard fruit to
pick
properly mango is another tough one very
tough to piss
[ __ ] pears ripen from the inside out
so you can't judge their ripeness by
looking at the skin
to test if a pear is ripe apply gentle
pressure near the stem end
and if it gives slightly it's most
likely ready to be eaten if they're left
on the tree
to ripen they become quite mealy
and unpleasant in texture well i'll tell
you this i did that push in up by the
stem area it gave a little
and it still was nowhere near like the
pair i had a couple of people so if
pairs if you're listening
and we know that you are if you're
listening and we know that you are
you might want to have a meeting with
each other and maybe somebody
set some parameters so you're all on the
same page because what you're doing is
you're ruining pay some of you pays are
ruining it
but buying here's the thing too you
can't compare the green period the other
day to the period a few weeks ago
if the other pair wasn't a green pair it
was green
you know pears are like apples there's
like seven
or eight different kinds and you gotta
if you don't pick the right apple you're
not having the same apple experience
can i ask you a question downstairs the
pair i had that was succulent
what was that pair called
aju anju and then what was the one i had
yesterday that pale
comparison did you see what just
happened no
pimp spelled on jupiter correctly no way
no way no no way he just laid a lot of
as my grandmother would say
he nailed it how did this is the word
that's
is spelled his guess was right so you
know that's a difficult word to spell
because he usually just just has a
seizure and then just hits consonants
and vowels
and hopes it comes out okay all right so
we got
we got a there's the gr see now that
look at that one
that's a green and red on you here's a
red anju versus a green and red versus a
yellow
pair heavy star meeting pears
i mean it's heavy stuff you can't have
this many representatives out it muddies
the
communication dude that picture the
fourth of july
barbecue chicken is making me so hungry
right now i'm going out of my mind i'm
so hungry
oh my god look at that picture pimp put
it up on the how good is that roasted
corn on the cob next to it with a little
chardonnay so the people can see it you
know what i mean
but let these people see this picture oh
the the perfect char
give this picture to the people look at
that look at the char on the look at the
char on the corn
i i i just said that oh that i think you
meant to char the chicken
i said the cherry on the corn oh okay
well the chard of the chicken too look
at that i love it
i love a good charm how good is a good
char great have you ever had a bad char
yeah
char is good no matter what would it be
great if there was something you want to
know about your
they're consistent what if you get what
if you went to a barbecue place tonight
you just had something called char
and it was just pieces of charred skin
from chicken
the way you put it just now sounds
barbaric it did it would but
i need it though i love a good chunk i'd
eat and it had a little dipping sauce
with it
i'd eat it in a second yeah it sounds
weird when you say charred skin but yeah
whatever they may have been called the
popularity of these twisty treats
spread what is this oh why pretzels oh
pretzels oh sorry
i guess yeah well let's get into the i
was like
yeah right potato chips versus pretzels
you are taking
let everybody guess what do you think
joe's taking
see if you get it right go ahead joe
you're wrong
cause i know you all guessed i was gonna
pick pretzels and no
i'm taking potato chips this man has the
audacity
to sit here and try to defend pretzels
that's right not even against potato
chips
just trying to defend pretzels you know
in general
you don't like pretzels you've heard my
thoughts on the combo
uh i'm from philly i love a soft pretzel
but once you get outside of the soft
pretzels soft pretzel
pretzel wrecks your entire category
alone
no a hot soft pretzel that's not what
we're talking about today
we're talking a variant pretzel or a hot
sauce we're talking about you know
you know a nice soft hot new york city
street pretzel or yankee game president
i love it i love a hot pretzel
that's what we're talking about today
we're talking about a hard pressure
whole shop
we're talking about a hard pretzel that
goes in a bowl at a barbecue nobody's
putting out soft pretzels at a barbecue
okay all right you can't buy a bag of
soft pretzels
as a snack i'll defend you on the
pretzel itself
bring it i love pretzels i want to hear
what you're going to do with this
pretzel
i'm all ears potato chips are very
overrated it's only interesting
it's only until the kettle the kettle
chip boom of the last decade this is how
you turn it into their own
this is blaze the original ladies that
cheat
nothing against these companies but they
have certain versions of chips i like
and certain versions i do not like
an utz chip i have added another chip
very similar to a lay's original or a
wise
or is lays made by white you're
interested in blaze wise
and us that bare bone chip
that non-kettle non-ruffled
bare bone original chip lays
wise is what i think of
when the potato chip has to send a
representative well then
and that is the worst potato okay but
then don't place
potato chips bland and it's oh it's not
flaky and bland
if you dip one of those chips into an
onion dip you're sorry
it's been a disappointment my whole life
even even in grammar school when you get
like chips as a side like when you get
like a lunch or whatever and they give
you that mini bag of not for resale
chips
that's like 100 calories you break it
open there's a few big ones a few small
ones it's a grease trap
you don't have to taste this you don't
have to prefer that that's why there's
9 000 other kinds of chips you can get
you can get air puff potato chips you
can get ruffled potato chips
you can get potato sticks if you want to
get a little crazy
uh you can get you can the flavors
alone pringles uh you know bake chips
all you got with pretzels buddy you got
bites
you got rods you got twisties
and then sometimes they have a honey
mustard flavor and that's it
you're game you're over dude
do yourself a favor and google sniders
of hanover
and then get back together i'm a fan of
that you're kidding me i'm getting
buffalo i'm a fan of this night i'm
getting hot and spicy i'm getting the
honey mustard
the nuggets the chips i'll get the box
of the hard snyders the thick ones and i
dip them in a dark mustard
it's a nice little treat oh it's more
than nice it's a nice little treat
you ain't messing with chicken you're
getting your extra dark
you're getting your thick you're getting
your rods you're getting your nuggets
you're getting your twists you're
getting your minis
come on with the pretzel now the pretzel
did everything they could do with the
pretzel the pretzels don't need
everything out and everyone has a
hundred different uh this every oil this
kind of crisp this kind of rough
everything sour cream and onion cheddar
it's great everything that could have
been done with the pretzel
started and ended with the chocolate
covering that was it
they hit i'm not even gonna bring that
in because chocolate pretzel i think
it's the best
snack of all time hey listen it's a
great snack
but they hit their ceiling they hit it
early and they ran out of trouble
covered
there's been no indiv yes not as good at
all not even close
i don't need chocolate on my potato
chips let's take it out of the equation
i don't even want my point
once you enter chocolate into the mix
with pretzels they hit their ceiling
it's what made pretzels and ice cream
good it makes me makes the chocolate
cover pretzel good
that's not the point i'm not gonna argue
chocolate the point is potato chips
still being innovated after all these
years you know what you'll never see
guess what our new flavor of pretzel is
like no company does that
you never walk down the stack aisle you
never walk down the stack aisle and go
holy [ __ ] they have pickle flavored
pretzels
new flavors of potato chips every year
dude you need the help
because without the pickle and without
the cheddar
and without the sour cream and onion and
without the salt and vine
all you are is a boring potato
that's all you are but you need all that
help all i'm saying about the building
if you really wanted to rip potato chips
you would be like you would square up
right now and be like
classic potato chip versus classic
pretzel
and classic classic chip over classic
pretzel eight day of the week
you would take you put it on a regular
chip you put it over a pretzel you put a
thin
regular old schneider's or whatever
classic pretzel
the classic thin little twisty thing
into a bowl
next to a bowl of chips i don't even go
near the pretzels nah
i won't go near i could eat pr i could
eat potato chips as a meal
because it's a if i was in a pinch if i
was in a pinch i wouldn't want to
but if i was in a pinch i could eat
potato chips as a meal
because it's a real food well you could
get a potato meal it's the cornerstone
stone of american cuisine
everything is built on the potatoes you
think the potatoes it's the cornerstone
of american cuisine one of them is one
of them
it's one of them how many foods do you
see in prepping that's lofty how many
foods you see how many meals you see
outside of the pretzel roll how many
times you see in pretzels don't
strike the thing that the top i'm saying
though
in a pretzel roll if you ever see a
sandwich on a pretzel roll they're
starting to do it at fast food places
now we ever go to like a diner or a nice
bar and grill or bavarian spot or
whatever
and they're like yeah we put this on
pretzel bread you don't do it dance no
you don't do a pretzel brush you don't
do a little no i hate pretzel bread
i don't like pretzel bread i don't like
pretzel bread say it one more time for
the people in the back i don't like
pretzel bread that's crazy
yeah that's what's not crazy i like
what's all you like about it
because like a soft pretzel yeah
but it tastes so much like bread and i
don't think a soft pretzel has any
goddamn business being around my
sandwich i'm sorry
i'm sorry you told me
you talk about innovation in chip but
you won't allow the pretzel to branch
out into being the bread
that happens left the snack
left the pretzels you know what category
pretzels category
with pretzels you're in there with rye
chips
[Music]
with chex mix oh you're right you're off
you're right you're in
you're in real life you're in real
mad like sort of like these are the
snacks they let us have at the convent
kind of territory with pretzels in a
chex mix then you could then then then
i'm done
if you're gonna use the pretzel and the
chex mix as a negative then i want
the chocolate dip pretzel as the
positive don't tell me that it's in the
medley of stuff you don't like
nobody talking
you would tell me that you would put the
classic potato chip unflavored against
my pretzel and you go down like a house
of cards my friend
are you bat [ __ ] you really fit
every sandwich shop in the world it's
potato chips just aside they never have
prices like we don't even do snacks just
snacks anymore now we're going into
sandwiches we're gonna be bread around
sandwich sally babe what's got zero
grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs
in each serving magic spoon that's right
magic spoon the best cereal that's only
140
calories per serving keto friendly
gluten friendly
uh or free baby excuse me keto friendly
gluten free grain free
soy free low carb gmo free
i mean magic spoon does it all they do
everything right for you
you can get some stuff that you like
that tastes like the
cereal you had when you were a kid but
it's actually
nutritious this is delicious it's super
healthy cereal that really brings you
the joy
in the morning that you're looking for
you know what i like we all need a
little joint when you order a bundle
because i normally don't buy
four cereals at a time right but when
you buy the bundle from them because
they're not huge huge boxes so it's cool
and you get four and then i have all of
a sudden boom i have a library of
cereals
yeah i like that i like going in the
morning and be like what is my mood
today i love it i love it so go to
magicspoon.com
taste buds you're going to use the promo
code taste buds and you're going to save
five bucks off your order don't forget
about their
100 happiness guarantee if you're not
happy you get your cash back
again magicspoon.com taste buds use that
promo code taste buds
save five bucks thanks magic spoon i was
on the web last week trying to buy
shampoo like i do
yeah and they they were tracking my
information i know it knew i realized i
didn't have my button hit
of my expressvpn it's cool this is what
happens when you have expressvpn
if you want to log on you hit the button
and then you see this little green
ring go around and it lights up that
you're protected and i need to know i
cannot go on my phone on my laptop right
now
without knowing i'm protected from
expressing it that's where i'm at
and i agree in this world we're living
in i mean you go to buy something simple
like shampoo they track you know
every single website you visit all the
internet service varieties know every
single one you visit
they can sell the information to ad
companies and tech giants who then
use your data to target you expressvpn
creates secure encrypted tunnel between
your device and the internet yeah
okay i get it i love it i don't i i do
not i mean this is i really don't use it
i do not use this no i use it all the
time
uh since they've come on board and i
really enjoy it and uh i'll tell you
this
don't forget people biggest money-making
industry in the entire world is selling
people's information that is the biggest
money maker in the world
so keep that in mind and out and while
you have it on your mind
go to expressvpn.com tastebuds that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com taste buds today go there and
you're going to get three extra
free months three free months on top of
whatever you get at expressvpn.com
taste buds go now potato chips go into
sandwiches all the time they go on the
cider sandwiches
potato cake sides are served as bread in
in jewish
uh delicatessen sometimes instead of the
bread cakes
you don't get potatoes you don't get you
don't get pretzel roll then
you don't get pretzel rolled in whatever
yeah
oh that's another beautiful thing they
do they use pretzel as
a what where they pretzel who does this
pretzel crusted chicken
yeah yeah pretzel crusted chicken that's
classic right that was the third uh
thing they were gonna have a kfc it was
going to be extra crispy original recipe
or pretzel crust
you ever bite into a beautiful thick
crunchy sourdough that's like
this big we're not talking about
sourdough you got a pretzels
you could dip a pretzel into any dip
that you could dip a potato chip into it
yes you can how dare you how dare you
eat the dip you cannot do
pretzels french onion dip is not good
potato chips are french oni dip is good
are you stupid in the head
what a dumb thing to say what a dumb
thing to say i feel like i actually have
to defend you
on saying something so look at this look
at this thank you pip
the potato chip was invented in 1853 by
george klum
a native african-american chef you
racist
you're racist wow the potato was
invented in saratoga springs
isn't that also where um isn't saratoga
springs where uh
saratoga peanut butter i would i would
assume so
where were pretzels invented
pretzels where were they invented in the
middle of middle ages
that's the sad snack you're behind
versus the middle
ages yeah that's pretty sad been here
[ __ ] yeah brussels has been here
yeah since the plague so what this is
this is what people ate when there was
no
choice let's go back to what there was
no choice but don't skirt what i said
a pretzel is more versatile than a chip
i believe
sound you know that's not true
it's as versatile no you know that's not
true it's not you just said that a
pretzel dipped in french
there is a hole not good there is a
whole industry based on potato chip dips
nobody is looking at this
you need all the extras you need it but
nobody nobody can look at me with a
straight face and tell me
that you can't dip everything you could
dip a chip into you could dip a pretzel
don't deny it okay accept it and we'll
move on guess
i could dip a twinkie into all those
dips it doesn't mean it's good it is a
classic joe
doesn't mean it's good it is good dojo
it's a crunchy salty treat
that that serves the same purpose i'm
not gonna dip a twinkie
into french onion dip do not make these
arguments
i'm not gonna dip a pretzel on the
french onion dip i'm sorry grease trap
what do you mean grease i hate greasy
hands i hate them
i touch my face my face agrees i touch
my your khakis
good luck with having chips when you're
wearing khakis
khakis fires what
is it that transpires when you eat food
that you are getting so messy every time
you're eating what are you
doing on a napkin if
[Music]
actual factual reasons the the
of the potato chip experience we're
gonna use i'm drawing negatives
out of the potato chips you're gonna use
that does not happen to me when i eat a
pretzels
it's something i don't like about the
potato juice why would i not use it stop
it you dip your hand and by the way you
dip your hand into that bag
and the reverse foil side of that wise
bag or that utz bag
is just coated in grease you're going
all over your knuckles
you're going after a very specific type
of potato chip
this does not apply to oh that's not
true any chip that's not true
any potato chips is baked cooked with
oil and by the way
you're over here haranguing maybe not
metal chips being there your favorite
they're the they're the most oily of all
the chips they're the kettle chips well
i i but the crunch makes up for it
i love a dark rustard i will say that a
dark russet a nice duck recipe
sweet potato chips there's no sweet
potato pretzels
there's no sweet whatever pretzels
there's no variation of the pretzels
it's a pretzel it's twisted up dough
that if you put chocolate on it it's
fantastic and if you don't
it's whatever this variation of the
pretzels because pretzel crisps came out
of nowhere in the last decade
and they have taken over a market share
like you wouldn't believe and from shark
tank i know
that real estate on shelves in places
like target and one-stop shop department
stores
are hard to come by i guarantee you if
you go down the pretzel aisle in a
target
where real estate is is is very very
spare
you're going to see pretzel crisp out
the ying yang here's a product that
innovated the pretzels and then it's yet
another balls
the balls on this company they got a
picture up and pimp i want you to put
the picture here
they got a picture of a pumpkin they got
a picture of a 2d pretzel
in guacamole as if anybody in their
right mind would go
i'm going to make some fresh guacamole
do me a favor sweetie
go get me some tootie pretzels
not the corn chips go get me some 2d
pretzels
for the fresh guacamole we just made in
the backyard
what are you calling them 2d pretzels
that's what they're called 2d oh because
they're flat
yeah oh two deep pretzels you're crazy
if you have you had a pretzel crisp i'm
not saying they're bad i'm saying
they're trying to sell it as an
alternative to the corn chip for a bowl
of guacamole
madness and they're succeeding know your
madness open your eyes okay
and go to i want you to go to the
optometrist and i want you to get a new
prescription
for your stupid-ass glasses because the
pretzels are doing things in front of
your face
that you're refusing to acknowledge or
your eyeballs can't see
i mean okay has moved into your
territory
the and now they also have those um
hollow shell pretzels
they look like nuggets or rods but
they're actually hollow and they provide
the same chris as a pretzel crisp
those are coming on strong from bachmann
where are they coming on strong from
seen one in real life it's bachmann
that's doing it i said three times in a
row yeah
yeah and they had to that's how candy
man candy man that's how shitty the and
filling the snack is is that they had to
make a hollow version of it
they had to flatten it down so you'd
even consider dipping it into
something peanut butter filled pretzels
what about those
they're great they're great
here's what i want to do next to a
potato it is no doubt in our minds right
no pickled potato chip
salt and vinegar potato chip i mean
you're who are you even dancing with
today
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna deny those
flavors but i would like to make a point
that i think
is a relevant point in light of that
all those flavors of potato chips they
add something to the selection they add
something to the potato chip itself they
elevate it it might be innovative
they have options and stuff like that
without a doubt i think though the
partial is that you really need it i
think if you were just selling
bags of salted potato chips like how the
pretzel can stick maybe it might change
the shape like a pasta
but at its core it's the pretzel with
salt no matter the shape i think you
stuck with that narrative with a potato
chip
they would have fallen off long ago i
think potato chips need it
and i do believe if you think about it
why why hasn't the pretzel
need to branch out in the way that the
potato chip has needed
to i believe the potato chip needed to
branch out
to save itself here's the [ __ ] with your
argument has stayed
still here is the fault because you
don't need to
deviate from all that money here's the
phone with the argument you
can't deviate that much you're speaking
as if there's an option to do
a barbecue pretzel tastes good it would
taste like [ __ ] i'm sorry but it doesn't
it does yes it does it tastes good lays
was the leading potato chip brand in the
united states with 1.7 billion dollars
worth of sales in 2017
accounting for approximately 29.6
of the potato chip market that year pip
please i want to see in the united
states 550 million dollars worth of
pretzels sold annually
okay i want to see the market on potato
chips versus pretzels
most eaten snacks i would i would i'd
have to imagine that potato chips has
that
because it's more expansive in but i
will go back
i will go back to my what i was saying a
minute ago
okay you're speaking as if there's a
versatility factor with the pretzel
that the that the potato chip has and
there isn't there is
the pretzel uh has is can you scroll up
a little bit
no that wasn't it what's better for you
pretzels are lower in calories
each serving of potato chips contains 21
grams of fat
uh each serving of pretzels has just two
grams of fat yeah
but it's soaked potato chips are ten
times as fattening
okay but it's carb you're also eating
something that is carb ridden
and if you want to talk fast knock knock
hello who's there the potato
the potatoes pretzels carb
pretzels white flour dude it's way more
heavy
you don't like pulling out a pretzel rod
and holding it like a cigar and
talking and chewing on the cigar little
by little until you have a long version
of a cigar
that turns into a half version of that
cigar until you're down right to the end
no you don't like holding
it i don't like pretzels and waxing
poetic and then just putting it up like
this
you suck on the salt a little bit you
get a little pretzel taste you pull it
back down
you soften up you take a crunch now you
got a cigar half the size
you go yeah see you have all fun little
voices that you do
i don't i don't i don't care at all you
don't like this you don't like reaching
into a bag of chips
you don't like reaching a bag of cheese
you don't like reaching a bag of chips
and getting that five chips stack out of
it and
putting it in your mouth and feeling the
crunch down through the five levels of
chip
in your mouth you don't love that you're
gonna tell me you don't love that it's
wonderful it's wonderful potato chips
are so amazing
you didn't even give me mine i can give
you yours i didn't i don't eat a pretzel
slice crunching down on five chips but
i'm saying chips versus pretzel
i'm going pretzel i think pretzel's also
better with a beverage
it's literally what i said pretzels were
invented
to reward young children for learning
their prayers
this is why they were invented i just
said legend has it
also when they let nunsey
also what does that matter i i love this
product uh they make betting that is
earth friendly and cruelty free
on a selfish note that's a very selfless
thing they're doing a selfish note what
i like about buffy
is uh they their sheets are so
soft buffy the bedtime slayer yeah and
they have a comforter you can get
called a breeze that makes it so you
don't sweat it
i sweat all the time i need this i don't
have that one yet i got to order that
it's great no more night sweats 100
plant place design is breathable
keeps you comfortable at a temperature
in a way that polyester and downfield
comforters cannot
work now moving into the summer months
it works trust me i've had this problem
for years it works the breeze is made of
eucalyptus
fabric inside and out it's softer than
cotton it is
it naturally soothes this soothes the
skin it does
it's earth friendly it's hypoallergenic
which is awesome
plus it's a high thread count all right
so it shuts out the dust and the mold
and the mites and it's cruelty free it's
great
can i say the best part though the free
trial because you can order the
comforter
try it at home in your own bed and then
you can if you don't like it
you don't have to keep it it's
unbelievable so get 20 bucks off your
buffy comforter by visiting and by the
way they have other comforters there too
uh by visiting buffy.com.com
that's co yeah buffy.co and you're gonna
enter
taste buds as your code you're gonna get
20 bucks off
your comforter all right okay so for 20
bucks off what we just said
off your buffy comforter visit buffy.com
and enter the code
taste buds if you watch podcasts you
probably know about blue chew because
they are
what's the word i'm looking for
ubiquitous in the podcast world is it
not
yes bluechoo has been around the podcast
space for a long time thank you bluechu
you're helping a lot of the podcasts out
that's very nice of you
and you have a very uni unique online
service they're delivering you the same
active ingredients as
viagra or cialis but in a chewable
tablet
and at a fraction of the cost i like
that you can
take these things anytime you want day
or night and so you can plan ahead
you can pick the type of tablet you want
that suits your needs a little bit
better do you need to be ready now you
need to be ready later
and if you don't know what we're talking
about by now people this is stuff for
your boner
right yeah yeah uh the best part it's
all done online so you don't got to go
visit a doctor there's no awkward
conversation there's no waiting in line
at a pharmacy that stuff is weird
sometimes you know so
they're gonna ship it right to your
house in discrete packaging made in the
usa
let us hook you up okay you're gonna go
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code taste buds and
it's gonna let you try blue chew
for free you're just gonna pay your five
dollar shipping at checkout
okay bluechew.com promo code tastebuds
first month
free bluechew.com
promo code buds first month three you're
paying five bucks for shipping and
that's it
all right for more details and important
safety information we thank blue chew
for sponsoring the podcast
so it's a joke i'm bringing up
some type of concrete arguments my
argument bringing up the user experience
of a chip
why i don't like it that it's greasy
what i'm i'm giving
i'm doing the same solid point i'm doing
this telling me that what i don't like
about pretzels i am doing the same or i
will do the same if i haven't done so
already i feel that i have
but just to appease you pretzels too
many carbs
bland you could eat too many carbs i can
say whatever comparison is a potato
you might have more coffee potato chips
carb
carb which is more carbs pretzels or
potato chips
white bleach flour is a basic ingredient
in
almost every pretzel you're going to eat
it's one of the worst things you could
ever put into your body
okay thank you thank you so much uh
uh uh uh one ounce of pretzels raised
blood sugar higher than one ounce of
potato chips there's your answer you
happy now
well why is that my answer that because
it's carb heavier
you may think that only one gram of fat
per serving pretzels
are a virtuous snack no refined carbs
but
essentially refined carbs you cannot
compare a naturally occurring carb
to the types of carbs and pretzels it is
two different types of carbs it's like
saying eating bread is the same thing as
eating carrots
you have ten times more fat and
saturated if you buy ones that are made
terribly and and whenever you can get
plenty of potato chips that aren't made
that way i loaded with that bro you want
to go down this road and go down the
road all day
you can get a bit would you say you can
get you want to go down this road you
can get a baked pretzel it doesn't
matter if it's baked it still has all
the carbs in it still has the white
beans but it's
talking about alternatives to the
regular
sal every pretzel you get is
no they're fine sometimes i'll say the
same thing i said about combos before
i eat them when i need to fill up and
i'm i'm dr i'm driving and i don't want
to like
eat like a big meal a lot of times
people eat either these snacks
sucks about a pretzel crunch it's
heavier than a chip than a pretzel yes
100
you can hear a chip you can hear a chip
say that
you can hear a chip crunch a ruffled
chip you hear a crunch
of course i'm not deaf you can hear a
pretzel crunch i'll tell you what it
takes about a pretzel too
when you bite it right here you can't
hear a pretzel when you bite a kretzel
when you bite a pretzel pencil
i've never heard of pretzel crunch but
when you bite a pretzel especially one
of your precious pretzel sticks
your shirt is covered in crumbs okay
every time
you gotta put a i can't complain pimp
agrees with me
you don't think the potato chip is the
is you put the whole chip in your mouth
you put the whole chip in your
championship is widely known
to be one of the messiest treats you
could eat your hands get greasy
you push the whole thing the chips go
everywhere people people wake up with
chips all
it's it's it's it's a trope it's amazing
people have chips
yes it true
it is true that if you lay on your back
eating potato chips drunk
you might get chips on yourself that's a
great counterpart
a pretzel can do better you're out of
your mind
so you put a whole chip in your mouth
you have to bite a pretzel several times
what about dipping pretzels and
beautiful nacho cheese
never been a fan never been a fan of the
pretzel dipped in cheese ever
i never when i got the pretzel bites at
the movie theater i would just go i go
don't give me the cheese
because chips i never heard a seinfeld
episode based around a chip
huh these pretzels are making me thirsty
i mean you want to talk cheese babe
let's talk about all the cheese flavored
chips for adults
oh god
it's a pretzel you know you got a bowl
of chips a bowl of pretzels
let's go let's go let's go to the
comments it's about that time i want to
hear we we
we bang that only a snow-capped living
90-year-old would pick pretzels there
you go
eric chong uh in in so far in the lead
for the best
pretzels are just the first one let me
tell you it's a funny it was a funny day
you demand to go to the phones without
checking number one every week
you want to somebody's got to steer this
[ __ ] back okay if it was up to you
on the second episode right let me say
something right now let me tell you
something right now
you read these and you dole out you dole
out prizes rewards and accolades
as soon as you read them and i think
you're too quick on the draw with that
all right you read the first thing you
go
bookmark that that's the current winner
so far right well you only read one
all right i said stop stop rewarding so
easily
it's really good good i'm sorry i like
what the fans say
i'm sorry that wasn't that cool why
doesn't like the fans everybody what can
i say you should hear what he says when
the cameras are offense
[Music]
all right i just said so far that's the
funniest one pretzels are just you read
one
all right pretzels are disgusting no
taste just leaves you with dry mouth not
true you know they have party mixed
chips and for some strange reason every
time
you put it out for a party only the pet
pretzels ripping
yeah pretzels need a flavor to be
tolerable
a chip is just simply i couldn't
disagree more with these people
guarantee sal's gonna say he messed up
and didn't specify crunchy pretzels and
he's gonna be upset lol eating pretzels
makes me feel
like i'm better than everyone you might
as well serve potato chips with a noose
peasant yeah
that's that's what i said that's a
contender for best uh tweet
uh come on pretzels can be dessert or
tasty snack potato chips have one
purpose and that's to make a sandwich
more filling
uh as joe will say no one has ever
walked into a 7-11 and greg
grabbed a bunch of bag of chips pretzels
away see i told you they were the
greatest thing you reversed it but you
do make blanket statements like that
that's so you no one has ever walked
into a 7-eleven
it's hysterical it's fun these there's
too many varieties of flavors to not
vote chips they have something for
everyone i adore pretzels but chips just
have
such better flavor varieties yeah but if
guys if you gotta douse your chip
and you don't have to or cheddar you
don't have onion or sour cream
but you don't have to you put out
pretzels you want people to leave
international symbol for party over
nah that's not true eating a pretzel is
like eating a salty piece of chalk
here i'm getting hammered in the
comments yeah god appreciate the
versatility of the potato
you're you're acting as if people don't
like playing potato chips they do
but as a bonus they can become all of
these other things
by the way potato chips also serve as an
ingredient for
goofy breading on fried chickens and
things like that get into goofy
breadings now
all right but i'm just saying like
potato chips stayed but
salted potato chips standard fair
straightforward original they would have
failed a long time ago
they needed they needed all the other
flavors and innovations
to maintain a market share and kept
getting better
why don't pretzels do the same exact
thing they don't need
it that's like saying that's like saying
if all in the family was truly a great
show
norman lear wouldn't have needed to do
all those spin-offs it's like no dude
i got a banger here and i'm gonna keep
on banging
i'm gonna keep growing out the brand i'm
going over here with good times we're
going over here with the jeffersons
take your pick babe whatever you want
not a bad comparison in light of some of
the atrocious comparisons you've made on
this show
pretzels are the snacks a mother buys
when she starts loving her new man more
than her children
that might have been too personal
[Laughter]
oh come on that's the winner that's the
word pretty good that's the winner
retweet this kid
alex berg wins at icyberg art four
the number four follow alex on twitter
all right let's go to the polls
what do you i think you're gonna i think
it's gonna be a slaughterhouse five
because
yeah because potatoes well we've gone
really fast then if there's only 12 so
far
you might want to refresh that pimpy no
i mean sometimes it's not all right i'm
ready for the drawing only because a
potato chip is
more popular
[Laughter]
that's bad that might be the biggest
have we ever had it over 80
yeah i think we've had one no not over
it might be up in the top one or two
seventy eight
point seven percent in favor of potato
chips
twenty one point three percent i
no way no way i thought i was getting
left out in the cold that bad
damn oh my goodness oh that feels good
i needed a win uh yeah yeah yeah i
needed a nice little oh my god
that is a that is that is bad guess what
humble pie we didn't even we never
introduced the the scientists
yeah all right god bless guess what
i still love you i love you too
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds